hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the Grantchester it's the London
chest classic and the four players are
now battling it out to see who will take
the well first place in the integrand
chester magnus carlsen maxima Sheila
Grove Delia and 11 are announced so here
from round one a nice classical game
between Magnus and MV l and here again
we have a bit of a different time format
it's a hundred and thirty players per
player sorry a hundred and thirty
minutes per player and you don't get any
increment there's a 30 second delay
starting from one and there is no time
control where you are awarded additional
time so no additional time has moved 40
60 or whatnot so you have what you have
you have the thirty seconds delay and
that's it you will not be awarded any
any additional time so it's it's it
tends to get things a bit more
interesting so that being said let's
check out the game and as usual when
Magnus plays against them via weed or
see I don't know why but lately it's
it's either MVL shows how to play the
groom felt then Magnus shows how not to
play the groom fault aurilla do we have
a nice night or so here it's a again a
nice night off and it's just well or
fireworks in round one so let's check it
out
efore by Magnus with c5 by anvil the
Sicilian defense Knight to f3 d6 and d4
captures captures we have Knight c3
Knight sorry Knight c3 Knight f6 Knight
c3 and a six and we have denied or
Sicilian on the board with the ship to
g5 e six and now f3 going for the setup
you would well usually play against a
dragon Sicilian for example the idea
being Queen d2 you want to Castle
queenside and you want to start pushing
points on the Kings side if black for
example castles King side but with h6
bus back to e3 and now b5 by mvl are
preparing to fianchetto the light square
Bishop with a3 stopping b4 and Knight B
to d7 now we have Queen to d2 ignites
the c6 you can play this but it doesn't
really do anything the Queen just moves
and then you
after mousse denied back so Queen to d2
preparing to Castle queenside and the
now Bishop to b7 and here there is one
game that reached this position where g4
was played it was a game played between
a 1900 player and the 2500 player were
the 1900 clear started lounging at the
black King but here Magnus just castles
Queen side and it is as of move 11 that
we have a completely new game so here of
course MVL doesn't want to see a move
like g4 so here we have h5 which will
make it harder for white to break
through on the Kings side King b1 always
a useful prophylactic move and Bishop to
e7 by MBL with Quinta a1 by Magnus and
now comes Luke the c8 now he wants to
get the Queen to c7 and put some
pressure along the C file where as if if
he's able to put d5 in before he should
get a very nice attack going so rook the
g1 by Magnus and now Queen to c7 as
planned and here Magnus took some 30
minutes that he said what to play here
and he played the g3 a slow positional
move in the future he wants to play h3
and g4 but he really wants to get Luke
to g2 in that will well defend the seat
upon later on so you will be able to
move this night we'll be able to move
this Knight you you will always have a
nice defender of the c2 pawn so instead
of g3 a queen queen g3 might look
interesting as it attacks the g7 pawn
but here black would actually encourage
you to capture it and you do not want to
capture it if you capture it you get
rook h7 the queen is under attack if the
Queen moves Queen g5 look h5 attacks the
Queen again the Queen g7 and Bishop to
f8 f 8 just traps the Queen or rather it
doesn't
since you have Knight captures any sex
but still black will be better yeah you
either have to give up a piece to get
your queen out of the way with Queen to
g6 check black will always be better
here and if just Bishop captures in g7
it's it's a clean piece and Knight
captures rook captures okay you do get
the d6 pawn so you get two points but
still black will be better so Magnus
goes for g3 like we said give it some 30
minutes think and here
we have 95 here it's one of those
positions you know how we always say
that you should always play d5 in the
Sicilian if it's possible so here this
is one such position and d5 is indeed
possible but it creates so many
complications that well it's just it's
just crazy it's hard to say if MVL ever
had this position on the board since
it's Magnus who came up with the
completely new game position but still
here it would just all hell would break
loose for example Bishop f4 attacks the
Queen and now if if AB you have it
captures on d5 which creates a
completely crazy game basically you
cannot capture the night because the
Queen hangs and if you capture the
bishop then you get Knight to the f5
already threatening mate and after Queen
to e5 blocking maid now d6 and this is
just a completely wild stuff Bishop f8
Queen captures on e5 Knight captures and
now rook to e1 will win back the piece
because well once the knight is defended
you just played G captures on f4 and win
back the piece so here white should get
the upper hand the problem is after each
character's on d5 this move you don't
have to capture the bishop you just play
Knight captures on d5 and you continue
the game in a nicely fashioned Knight
captures on d5 Bishop captures and now
the game continues
rook g2 will have to be played keep an
eye on this guy here and then then the
game continues but again it's just a
completely crazy position although it is
it is possible but mvl prefers knights
the e5 he wants to get to this night
over to c4 and here Magnus took another
20 minutes to come up with a reply as
there are a lot of interesting ideas you
could play h3 fall by g4 you could try
some some other ideas for example you
could try Bishop to h3 okay it does come
with the idea of sacrificing the bishop
on e6 followed by Knight captures and e6
but it doesn't work after Knight to the
c4 you could go Bishop captures F
captures the knight capture seems like
you already grabbed two points for the
piece you're gonna at least grab another
one the g7 pawn will fall with Czech
problem is Black has Knight captures on
a3
with cheque and now if you don't capture
a king a1 or King c1 run into Queen to
a5 or if you captured in just Queen
captures in c3 white loses the attack
and your peace sacrifice was in vain
Queen captures rook characteris and you
don't have knife caption g7 okay with
check King is going to attack the knight
a nice the f5 and now okay the bishop on
e3 is now guarded by the knight but
you're gonna bring the rook over here
and you will have an excellent game with
black White has no compensation here so
instead after 95 with rook to g2 by
Magnus just getting that defender in
there and now comes castles here Maxime
took some 10 minutes to think and he
decided to castle and said okay it's not
a problem you will not to be able to
create any sort of an attack on the on
the King side if someone is attacking
that's gonna be me on the Queen side so
Magnus plays h3 prepares to start
pushing on the King side but d5 and here
Magnus has to decide does he wanna trade
does he want to go Bishop the f4 or does
he want to keep the position closed so
he wants to keep the position closed and
attack on the King side if possible so
he decides on f4 pushes the Knight to c4
and now he can either capture on c4 at
preserve his bishop which is possible
the problem is after Bishop captures now
you play E D captures on c4 you don't
really have a good way of defending your
your pawn here so what what do you play
if a bishop to see one if you had
another defender to the pawn here just
before it's very strong and after it
captures Bishop captures it's black who
will have a very nice attack you don't
really care about points anymore at this
point
black will just have a very very strong
attack here so after Knight to c4 magnus
decided for a 5 and now Maxine has to
decide where he wants to go 94 or first
eliminate the dark square Bishop Bishop
both ideas are very much playable but
you know who could resist such a nice
dark square bishop so MVL grabs it we
have Queen captures and only now nights
the e4 we have Knight captures by Magnus
D captures on e4 and now comes Luke the
e2
preparing the
- gee - and this point will not be able
to withstand all of the attacks but MVL
says that it's not a problem here he
goes Bishop to d5
the idea is Bishop to b5 followed by
Queen to c4 he wants to threaten the a2
square another possibility was rook to
b8 it's also very interesting you just
say okay I don't care about this pawn
I'm just gonna give it up B for you you
start an attack from captures Bishop
captures and you have all of your pieces
are fully mobilized and you will you
will just have a very pleasant attack on
the Queen side but okay mvl decided for
Bush of the d5 as he's such an either of
expert it's it's hard to even imagine
how many neither of positions and how
many ideas in the neither of you know
regarding this type of attack this that
type of attack he already had at home
when you know preparing for some nice
neither of games but hard to say which
are but it he's such a creative player
that I'm sure most of it is actually
found over the board but okay Magnus
continues Bishop to g2 he has to go for
the pawn there's no other way around it
and now Queen to see for threatening
Queen to a to check and now if you block
with the b3 it is possible but after
Queen c3 black again gets the upper hand
for example you do grab your pawn but
Bishop captures on e4 Queen captures and
c3 rook captures and rook captures on e4
the problem is after rook F the c8 black
is perfectly fine you can grab the a3
point you can grab the g3 point so it
doesn't really matter that you're down
upon at the moment black will be better
in this position so after Queen C for
Magnus played Knight to b3 just blocking
blocking it that way and here we have
Bishop to c5 a deadly there for for
Magnus does he want to grab on c5 and
allow Queen to a to check so it's
basically a piece sacrifice and here
Magnus doesn't think about it for too
long he just grabs the grabs the bishop
and now black could just capture the
piece and then the game just continue so
we why white will play b3 pushed the
Queen back and the game continues but
MVL
wants to attack so quinta a to check
with King to see one the time on the
clock at this point is 40 minutes for
Magnus and one hour for MVA with King to
see one and now comes well if he tried
roped Quinte one check right away then
just King D two and then the King just
runs away if Queen captures son B to
King you want and now if Bishop to c4
attacking the Ruby just to look eat - D
- everything is nicely protected the
knight is protected you will capture on
e4 on the next move and the black does
not have compensation for the sacrificed
piece so after King to c1 rook F the b8
by MVL and now well if this bishop ever
moves the roof covers the DT Square
Queen to a-1 can be made so it's really
unpleasant position for white and a lot
of ideas are possible here but you know
it's just one of those positions where
you want to pause the video and try to
find it the best move for Magnus well I
give you a couple of seconds so you know
you can do that for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
finding an incredibly difficult move to
find but it's it's completely
counterintuitive but it it really just
saves white so first we're gonna show an
idea that what happens after Bishop
captures on e4 at that point the idea is
possible but then you have Queen a1
check King to d2 and now Bishop captures
on e4 with a discovery from the rook
Knight the d3 blocking and now Queen
captures and b2 this is an extremely
hard move to find not at this position
but when you start the variation because
okay you cannot capture due to the rook
but you give up the bishop on e4 point
is after Queen captures you have looked
the c-4 push the Queen back and after
Queen to have three Quintus III check
and now King III you can just go King
before check King here Queens to c3
checking the King III Queen d4 check you
go back and it's a draw by repetition of
move so really insane stuff if you try
to hide with looking to see one just to
okay for captures and its mate or severe
material loss so white will have to sell
for a draw here so Bishop to c4 captures
is a is a playable move but it's
basically a force to draw if place
perfection so here the move you had to
find was c4 and it's just like I said an
incredible country intuitive move
because you basically open up even more
lines in front of your king and there
are two hooks and there's a rock and see
it and on the eighth really
I just ready to crush the white king the
problem is it's it really creates
problems for black because just be
captures and c4 closes the C file and
you don't want to close your C file for
the rook on the other hand if you don't
do it you cannot move the bishop if you
move the bishop just rook captures rook
and white is able to trade down all of
the piece or if you just captured here
it doesn't matter
rook captures rook captures and then
looked a bit do you offer trades and if
Queen to a one check King - C - it's not
a problem
rook captures Queen captures and again
you don't you do not have compensation
for a sacrificed piece black has no ways
of continuing this attack so that will
not to do so after C for let's say Queen
captures on c4 with check again rook to
c2 now defense against check adds
another defender to the night so it's
not a problem Queen if coming back to a2
just ripped a d4 and you've created an
escape route for the King now if Queen
to a-1 you can start running away and
everything is nicely protected so here
after c4 be cat person c4 was played by
Maxine and well now you've basically
closed off the C file for the rook and
now you Magnus has a safety square on c2
for the King
so here Magnus plays rook eat the B to
add another attacker on the D file now
if the bishop moves you can just create
madness here on the d file there was
also the possibility and I'm just gonna
show it because it's a really really
insane
engine line that starts with Knight to
a4 the point is you want to bring the
knight back to c3 to use it for defense
problem is there's a bishop to c6
attacks the night now you trade a pair
of rooks captures captures and then
Mountain Knight to c3 with an attack on
the Queen Queen a 1 check and now you
have to block with the night if you blow
if you walk into c2 then Bishop to a4
wins for Black Knight captures Queen d2
cooing
one checking has the move and Queen to
b3 will be made
so after Quinta 1 check you have to
block with the night and now you get
rook to e3 and it's just again a really
disgusting position king a queen to g1
hat you have to move and now well it's
really complicated but why it should
have the upper hand so this was one of
the ways to go for example if c3 you can
just go Queen to eat one you add another
defender to the c3 pawn the problem is
if you capture here room just captures
and the black queen will never ever play
a move in this game since there's no way
to bring the Queen out it's just it's
just out of the game so I've definitely
a very interesting idea this Knight to
a4 but extremely complicated and well
there's simply too much at stake to go
into something if you cannot calculate
it all the way and also if you if you
don't want to invest too much time in
calculating it since there are no
additions in time in the industry event
so here look eat a d2 by Magnus and here
we have Queen - a1 check we have king -
c2 by Magnus and now mvl just repeats
queen - a - he wants the Queen and King
on this file as now c3 will be well it
will be a pretty big deal since you will
not be able to recapture with the b-pawn
and here we we just have king 2 c1
the problem is if you try something like
rook to see want to try running away
with your king here c3 is just a deadly
point is that after Queen captures on c3
you play Bishop to b3 now this comes
with check and after Queen captures on
b3 well now you just can't play rook
captures and c5 after the King moves you
you win the Queen so that's not not a
great idea but you could play Knight
character son b3 and then you have just
rook captures and c3 with check King
captures on c3 and now rook c8 check
King d4 and now rook captures on c1
Knight captures on c1 attacking the
Queen but you are able to wiggle out
because you have Queen to d5 check King
to e3 and now Queen
see five check finally picks up the
night and here you will regain material
advantage King captures any for now just
Queen captures unsee one and now of
course the Queen will win against the
the rook and the bishop most likely but
with such strong players playing this
tournament the probably yes so you can
do something like rook to c1 if you try
Bishop characters on e4 then just the
rook captures on c5 is enough to the win
if Queen captures then you just play
Bishop captures I need four with check
and everything falls apart there's a if
you go back King c1 then Queen a1 is
made so your only other option is to
block your with the rogue but here we
just gobble up everything see captors
and III with check King moves you put
the pawn and now you just win the game
so after Quinta a to Magnus really
doesn't have a good move he's up a piece
he he you know he is not in any obvious
danger but well but he is c3 is a
terrible threat so here he just repeats
King to c1 and we have just Quinta a1
check King goes back Quinta a2 and after
King to c1
it was in this position that the players
agreed to a draw here it you might think
okay well why not just c3 it must work
well it's it doesn't because here the
Queen can just capture and it's not a
problem because there's no Bishop to b3
to come with check so here you don't
really have a good way of continuing the
attack if Queen a1 check the King just
moves to c2 and there's no continuation
now if the Queen goes here it doesn't
really do anything as you have this very
very vertical resource of Bishop to f1
and now black just black no longer has
the attack
now if Bishop to b3 check which is what
you what you want to do you have Knight
captures on b3 rook captures on c3 with
check yes you win the Queen and now you
get King captures and c3 rook captures
here and just Knight captures and there
well now like the black Queen will not
be able to play this against a rock
Knight and the Bishop of white will
definitely win this game so now after
this King to see one the players agreed
to a draw and well what a very nice
start of the of the London just classic
the finals of the Grantchester so where
I haven't checked on this game just
finished so I haven't checked out on the
ding vs. 11 since their game finished Oh
quite earlier but we're gonna check out
that game tomorrow as well unless it's
like a really big snooze fest then we're
not so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank dog
McNab hobbies' tonight Jeff Briggs and
Pablo Mohan for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
Grantchester it's quite a big event so
III do plan to cover it checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and after
that we are starting the next big saga
thank you all I will see you soon and
him an excellent rest of your day